hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast particle size
characterization by laser diffraction
analysis in Geoscience and soil science
background analysis application and
interpretation presented by dr. bjorn
marshall a we're excited to bring you
this educational web seminar presented
by lab routine sponsored by Beckman
Coulter life sciences Beckman Coulter
develops manufactures and markets
products that simplify automate and
innovate complex biomedical testing more
than 275,000 Beckman culture systems
operate in both diagnostics and life
sciences laboratories on seven
continents for over 75 years their
products have been making a difference
in people's lives by improving the
productivity of medical professionals
and scientists supplying critical
information for improving patient health
and delivering trusted solutions for
research and discovery to learn more
about Beckman Coulter life sciences
please visit www.gfi.com/webmonitor
active we encourage you to participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge that window just click on the
screen icon located in the lower right
finally if you have trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support
at the top right of the presentation
window or you can use the Q&A button to
let us know you're having a problem
thank you I would now like to introduce
dr. Boren Marshall a dr. Marshall I
obtained his PhD in geosciences at the
Humboldt University of Berlin Germany in
2011 by applying fine
scale particle size measurements on the
Beckman Coulter LS 13 320 laser particle
size analyzer he has developed novel 7
methodological proxies as a tool to
reconstruct past climate change dr.
Michele a has also pioneered the use of
detailed high-resolution particle size
analysis in studies of Aeolian death
sedimentary records
dr. Marshall a has been awarded many
fellowships and research grants he
currently holds a research fellowship by
the German Science Foundation and
continues his work on changing
atmospheric circulation patterns during
the Pleistocene across Eurasia at
various short and intermediate temporal
scales and regional to hemispheric
spatial scales his complete bio can be
found on the lab routes website please
join me in welcoming dr. bjorn michelle
a I will now turn the presentation over
to him Christina thank you very much for
the kind introduction
before I begin I would also like to
thank Declan CUDA life sciences and
leopards for their work and effort to
make this web seminar possible today in
today's presentation
I aim to highlight the capabilities
significance and potential to obtain
improved results and nava scientific
findings using laser diffraction
analysis as a tool to characterize
potato size distributions in the wide
field of Geoscience and soil science
after
overview where and why particle size
characterization is important to chill
and soil scientists at central part of
my presentation will focus on selected
case studies that illustrate that a high
measurement resolution and the high
number of detector elements are key for
state-of-the-art applications in few
scientific studies after that I will say
a few words on preparation and treatment
of children's material prior to laser
diffraction measurements but I will keep
this technical section rather short and
finally I think it's important to talk a
little bit about the occurrence of
subpopulations within white particulars
distributions and their significance and
to make you already a little bit curious
this background image here is um so
basically this one here it's not some
simple artwork or a randomly selected
particular distributions these are
several samples from a grinding
experiment on a ball mill showing the
continuous finding of particularized
distributions after a certain amount of
physical stress and time and this is
basically something I will cover in the
fourth chapter at the end of my talk
that start with the first chapter
particular aspect characterization and
its application in the field of
Geoscience and solid lines geological
landscapes are shaped by processes that
produce transferred and deposit mixtures
of particles and I think if you are
familiar vs. feared you know what I mean
was the center so if you look on this
nice picture here from the Bay of Kotor
in Montenegro it becomes evident that
particles produced transported and
deposited at many stages of this
landscape so basically in the mountains
on the slopes or in the river rivers in
the basins and even in the sea so
information on how sediment has been
produced and odesite finally encoded in
particular distributions
the particular size distributions evolve
after sediment production and they can
evolve by mixing from different sources
like let's say for example from the
mountains and Olien dust they can evolve
by size reduction by physical and
chemical attack or erosion and of course
say both by sorting during transport
into position
so if you just consider this landscape
here from the mountains through the
rivers to the river valleys or even to
the sea there at all stages particular
size distributions play a crucial role
you can measure particular surface
diffusion since mountains in the river
valleys or even you can measure the dust
that was blown out from the river is and
the fallen back to the edge of the
mountains so in just some animation to
show you this again and on the next
slide
yes and basically I'm here you can see
just two perfect effects of diffusion
and all these information we get from
these studies in the landscape are
finally stored in the particle size
distribution curve and it's our job to
analyze these and put them in a
scientific or context or in the context
of an application when the next screen
you see a few selected potential fears
from the geosciences where particulars
investigations can be applied for
example these could be it all in systems
were perfect size distributions will
tell us a lot about wind speed surface
conditions geomorphology variability of
atmospheric circulation patterns and so
on in fluid systems potato size
distributions are crucial to understand
flow velocity sediment suspension river
mythology the dynamic and the processes
of fluid systems and in marine limnic or
lacustrine systems say they tell us
something about flow and 13
Haitian dynamics the flu real order
they're only an input to a system so
this this is of course not complete and
I'm pretty sure you on the other side of
this screen work probably in one of
these areas or in another field from the
cheese lines and sauce discipline and
there are many potential fears where you
can apply particle size investigations
if we talk about particular size
distribution talked about particular
eyes in chios lines and saw signs
most scientists and users will deal with
fine clastic sediments in the size range
up to 2,000 micrometer in this size
range basically consists of three grains
affections clay below 2 micrometer silt
between 2 and 63 micrometers and then
from 63 to mm micrometers and everything
above 2000 micro meter above 2
millimeter we consider as crevel and
traditionally these cranes I sections
are all also divided the further though
that we call greven will only travel it
could because middle of fine gravel and
the same accounts for send you can
divide these grinders fractions down to
course and Millicent and friends and and
the same for third corset middle third
and finds it and traditionally
particular size distributions were
measured by sieving
or settling methods and some disciplines
from sub disciplines such as sedimentary
geologists and soil scientists still
hold on to that primarily owing to the
comparability of existing and archives
razaw standard specifications and even
though each particular size
characterization technique may have its
own scope of application
laser diffraction and as analysis offers
crucial advantages in their respective
field of application whether it is with
experiments or standard applications in
Geoscience and thoughts and most of you
will already know from your experience
that geological and solar science
samples in most cases neither
sophisticated and adequate pretreatment
procedure in order to achieve repeatable
and meaningful results and this could be
the removal of organics and this is of
course always a sufficient dispersion so
obtained particular size distributions
usually right in most cases there are
multimodal and also subpopulations or in
other words entire particular
distributions significant for answering
any research questions and need to be
accessible for data analysis and
interpretation and this has become as a
convex lenss means that a high
measurement resolution and the optimal
design of the analytical instrument are
both critical issues that are key for
reliable and comparable results and
original in innovative applications and
the next figure gives you an impression
on the variability of particulars
distributions of Chios and samples
collected from very different
environmental locations and geological
settings and I think this highlights the
last variability and if you just compare
from glacier rock flower and tune then
from Germany as a vast variability in
the risk of particle size distributions
and I think this is a nice picture that
shows you how the rival samples can look
like in Geoscience so if you just just
moved from so right to the left to this
blue but it was as the true fusion curve
which is as I already said tunes and
sediment from Brandenburg and Germany
the light green one is a soil sediment
from the Austrian art
um turkeys one is only in just 30 min
from China as this the one in total is a
marine sediments from the day of the
Gaza red one is a lake sediment from
Beth Ann Island in Canada and orange one
is a glacier rock flowers sediment from
New Zealand and there's one an
additional in this slide which is not a
natural sediment this is a dark green
curve the desert official says that be
produced in the lab okay with this slide
I would like to come to the second
chapter and elected case studies
including strategies and principles of
sample collection in the field and
laboratory um without obtained by
high-resolution particularized analyzes
using laser diffraction will greatly
benefit from adapted methods of sample
collection in the field as well as in
the laboratory and there are two
important considerations the first one
is that amount of sample material needed
for a single individual measurement is
considerably smaller compared to other
particle size measurement techniques so
just for example as you can see in this
picture here this is a typical amount
that even today in most soil scientists
for example will take a sample of about
500 gram that is usually taken from one
soil horizon and an amount that is
needed for laser diffraction is can be
as small as five 400 milligram and this
already includes replicates and material
that can set is left over for for the
archive and this I think is a makes a
huge difference if you compare 500 gram
and 400 milligram and and this also
gives you the probability and to carry
out much more detailed studies and tests
to show you how it looks like when you
sample in a very high resolution in the
sphere this is a picture from the
muttering last sequence in Serbia and
here we carried out two centimeter
intervals samplings particulars analysis
on this about 35 meter long sequence and
today most of the sediment cores or
sediment sequences remember we already
sample at 1/2 centimeter resolution and
however even if you have samples and
that they're taken by what the jar what
I call traditional sampling schemes or
you have archive samples from government
organizations let's say for example from
the geologic or soil science survey or
centers from studies where across a
sampling resolution is sufficient
they will also derive a significant
advantage from the application of laser
diffraction with a higher measurement
resolution and on the next window
there's a life extender that gives
testimony of this this was a study with
colleagues from the University of
Muenster and Germany and they wanted to
look on the habitat selection of a
specific mole cricket in the Pyrenees
and besides a few parameters they looked
at they also looked at at some
particular size also surface sediments
were and that this mole cricket
preferred and before we got in touch and
together they already had taken 500 km
surface soil samples and analyze them as
traditional sieving and sedimentation
techniques and they got a correlation
that was ok but but norick something
like zero point seven five and then we
analyzed these symbols they were not
that say the most perfect centers and
how I would have taken it in the field
it turned out that correlation between
the habitat selection and particle size
of of the sediments whether versus mole
cricket build its habitat was we really
hire those we have natural correlation
to send a very strong one and we have a
positive correlation the soot and clay
so showing that this mole cricket
preferred definitely sites this very
fine sediments the other consideration
is that an optimized simple throughput
and a high measurement resolution
another high-resolution sampling in much
more detailed studies and even though
precise sampling on geological exposure
sediment cores or soil profiles was
feasible in the past most studies did
not choose a high-resolution sampling
for particular studies due to the
limitations of laboratory labor and the
performance of the analytical
instruments and with instruments like
this one here the Beckman LS 13 320 we
are able to measure up to 150 samples
today and if you just say measure 5
times per week this comes to a
impressive number and means that you are
able to take much more centers in the
field increase your sampling resolution
now I come to the case studies I
mentioned before and the first and that
this case that is I hope will highlight
how above-mentioned considerations make
difference for the significance of
Geoscience in soil science applications
the first case study is on sediment
transport by tropical storms or tropical
cyclones that are recorded in a
submarine canyon of Bangladesh and this
is a collaboration with professor
Hammond coutras from the mahram in
premier in germany and already this
first picture shows you this fast impact
of cyclones to the
your finger is a cyclone this happened
in 2007 to understand and to predict the
long-term dynamics of seas and moody
takeda trends of these iconic events
that have often has very severe
consequences for the coastal region the
historical cyclonic records that exist
is too short too sparse
however the Cyclones have a massive
impact on the shallow water sediments
like here and we trace acute sediment
from the impacted shallow water area to
the coastal blame to the shelf
to the continental slope and finally
into Kenyon's such as this one here this
prominent swatch of no ground in which
serves as a major sedimentary trap in
the Bay of Bengal the particular signal
from this sedimentary record in this
virtue of no ground is expected to
provide a long-term archive to decipher
the frequency of economic events beyond
the historical cyclonic record to allow
a distinct characterization of sediment
transport and dynamics and to identify
sediment layers related to tropicals
iconic events we investigated a 362
centimeter long marine sediment core and
this one was samples for particular eyes
and analyzers at a sampling resolution
of 0.5 centimeter 1/2 centimeter the
particulars distributions were measured
using a Beckman CUDA LS 13 320 and
following the method that we described
in 2008 so results Pasillas I've
analyzed demonstrates that sediment
deposited in the canyon records a
sedimentary signal of cyclonic
events at a remarkable resolution each
graded pet or each storm layer which you
can see here
these dark layers here excuse me
each way that is marked by clearly
visible boundaries at the start and the
end of a sedimentary impact related to a
cycling event the most evident feature
at the beginning of each created that is
a sudden increase of the sand fraction
and a prop shift in the crane dies mode
from fine silt to find them which
reflects a powerful impact on the
sedimentary system at the onset of a
cyclonic storm I just try to point this
out a little bit with some marking here
and the figure so basically what I'm
talking about is is this part here but
we have this a prompt increase in Zent
content at the beginning of a cyclonic
event and then we Aziz's continuous
decrease in the sand size here and in
addition the high resolution particle
size data data makes it really possible
to retrace the whole sedimentary process
related to the impact of a cyclonic
storm and this figure really
demonstrates the Proms reaction of the
very material signal to the onset of a
cyclonic storm also allows us really to
trace the sedimentary imprints from the
very beginning of a stormy went to it's
complete as it just look at this storm
event or of this one here how much
something that and detector resolution
Medus becomes evident in the next slide
by convey compare a bigger size
distribution from each individual sample
taken at a continuous 1/2 centimeter
from sampling at home basically I'm
showing you now a few individual
particular distributions that are taken
from this interval here that you see in
this red square and in this figure
really demonstrates that it's possible
to fingerprints on set and the end of a
cyclonic event in the sedimentary record
following the changes in particular
distribution of consecutively taken
samples so basically the supply curve
here is either it's a particular
distribution at the pre-storm state and
then we see the continuous Cottenham of
the particular distribution curves
towards the red one where we have the
particular distribution curve that's a
fully developed tropical storm II went
and then the shifts from the red
particle size distribution curve to the
blue one it's already the declining
storm activity so you can really put
your finger here on the particular
distribution curve and you can see the
how the storm slowly begins and then we
have this fully storm developed and yes
a sudden increase in the sand content so
depicted here by this red you know
particular distribution curve the next
case study is systems science so the
next case study is a study from on high
resolution particulates analysis on a
lake sediment cross fit complex in the
Wind River Range in Wyoming this is a
collaboration with Professor Tom Davis
from the Bentley University in walsim
USA and if it just look on lake
sediments lake sediments provide usually
a very ideal high-resolution climate
proxies but they are not commonly
available in many geographic areas over
long timescales and in 1997 jean goss
hired a peck of horses to transport Tom
Davis sediment core equipment to the
vidcom Payson and during the sampling
campaign they obtained a couple of
sediment cause up to five point four
meter long and a few layer years later
we sampled the sediment cores for
particular analysis hoo-wee tempered a
five hundred twenty centimeter long
sediment quorum and used the Beckman
cruiser LS 3320 with the auto prep
station to measure both this is just a
map that gives you a location of the
sediment core so UT refers to upper
teeth complex energy as lower sitcom
plague and the position of core that I
trust were shown on the next slide is
from here and if you no idea how this
sediment core looks like so this is
lower Titcomb plank or two to the left
it's the top of the car and a couple of
analyzers that are carried out on this
core and pollen and LOI and a lot of
radiocarbon dating was performed on this
sediment core and on the next slide I
want to show you a few particulars of
diffusion Crawford saying exactly from
this middle part of the cross segment
which is approximately geochronology
economic theorists reject chronosphere
traffic border between the Jana death
and the Holocene
and what you see here basically 30
centimeters of samples taken from this
middle direction and I've shown you only
every fifth sample but you orally this
figure here with every system but it's
already a very busy figure but what is
very nice reversible is that we have
this distinct shift from finer sediments
to causes a diamond approximately
between between sample 500 and 500
science so basically we have one group
of samples as this very coarse part and
we have the other group members that
haven't this very the coarse grain
direction and if we put a time
information in this this is exactly the
boundary between the Junge triose in
blue and the holocene sediments in red
and basically this refers to the initial
nursing at the beginning of the Holocene
the Younger Dryas the landscape around
the lake was frozen and stabilized and
just when the Holocene our current warm
period started to happen or standard
this is initial warming we had a lot of
melting around in the landscape grounds
leg and a lot of causa sediments went
into the lake and this is exactly what
what shows you this figure here and
again likens the case study before you
can really put your finger on this shift
between one yeah unparticle sized group
and the other and can really say okay it
happens exactly here in between so as to
to those groups and finally what you can
do when you have these information
stored in your particular distribution
curve you can transfer every individual
particle size distribution data into a
Frederick graphical and paleoclimate
record so basically on the x-axis here
we have our H information and here in
this screen I calculated a parameter
based on just a very simple parameter
fraction causes and 63 micrometer and
this is shown here in this diagram shows
affection causes and 63 micrometer which
is basically the same fraction and this
shift I just showed you in on the figure
before is exactly where the red arrow
points to so this is here this is the
shift between seyoung at rio sediments
and the Holocene sediment so basically
it's beginning the Holocene the initial
melting so next case study is something
completely different it's on soil
development in agriculture terraces on
the nine hardener order in the in North
East Brandenburg in Germany so basically
north east of Berlin the collaboration
is Professor net from Samaj University
in the particulars characterization of
soils and soil horizons or soil
sediments is a standard procedure in the
field of science and the particulars is
diffusion or as it's called in all
Sciences oil texture is a parameter that
informs on sophistical properties of
soil but it's also the basis for many
other analysis and interpretation on the
nature of so and within the scope of
this project on agricultural terraces on
the noin had no other info we
investigated selected soil process and
Caesar also assembled and investigated
for high resolution particulars
analysis just to give you an idea how
these field terrace looks like you see
here this is a sequence of from all
three Co terraces with a recent surface
soil we have anthropogenic formed man
made from glulam and no that is a fossil
the horizon probably is
just former surface and we have fear
stones at the edge of these few terraces
the positions of the soil prophet in the
study are in the middle of this sequence
and just to give you a closer look to it
so this is how it houses stratigraphic
and the soil record looks like we have
at the top of the recent soil then a
Kalu viim this is a fossil be horizon
and the host material is composed by a
light plasticine organ sense that is
influenced by deadeyes dynamics and just
today i want to present your fewer
thought from this soil profile to a this
one in the middle and we did basically
the same as in the other case that is so
particulars analysis on 100 almost 120
samples from this profile so taking it a
2-centimeter sampling resolution well
measured with Beckman LS 13 320 we did
five measurement or measurement of each
sample and after sample preparation it
took only one day to measure 113 samples
with high precision and high
reproducibility and despite the small
scale differences between these three
individual particle size distribution so
the the red one the green one and the
blue one we have very distinctive
particular eyes changes within the
profile that we can basically visualize
by applying cranes eyes parameter that
take leverage from the high resolution
of the instrument so if you would have
analyzed this one see samples with her
was a technique with low resolution you
probably would just get a signal here in
the in the sensors but you wouldn't be
able to discriminate between these very
small changes between these three
samples but these rooms resemble
are really really different so the red
one is from the current a horizon the
blue one is a fossil B horizon and the
green one is the hospital C horizon so
this really gives us a possibility
there's a high resolution of the
instrument to go really into detail and
for example usually a soil scientist
would have looked on the content of the
clay fraction to get more information
about about soil development in this
profile but there's almost no signal if
you would now have all 190 members
that's overlay here you would see there
is basically no signal in the fraction
below 2 micrometer so it's really
helpful to have this high resolution in
the size range between 40 and 400
micrometer and this is I come to the
third chapter of my presentations of
preparation and treatment of Geoscience
materials prior to laser diffraction
measurements and an adequate handling
and treatment of Geoscience and soil
samples it's really paramount to obtain
accurate reproducible and meaningful
meaningful scientific results then
performing measurements for particle
size analysis on samples from natural
environments an optimized sampling
center handling treatment and
measurement scheme is basically built on
two pillars so one of them simple free
treatment here and the other one is a
technical territory for the instrument I
this talk I will really be very short
with some unconscious chapter and I like
to point you to get more information
about this in our upcoming application
mode so if you contact leopards and if
you contact Eggman they will tell you
more about this and how
gets us but I'd like to say a few words
about dispersion and water quality the
optimal dispersion of the temple
material is keyed to obtain consistent
and reliable results if example is not
well dispersed in the first place
any particulars characterization
technique will measure
accredits of particles instead of single
politics and if you want to measure ike
leggett this is fine but i think most of
us want to measure individual particles
a common effect and the other a very
useful test that can be often observed
when measuring in insufficient dispersed
central samples is a continuous
dispersion during a single measurement
or during subsequent measurements of the
same sample on a laser diffraction
analyzer and this is basically what
shows you this figure here this is
centered here 241 and it's five lumps of
this sample so it's the same sample just
measured again and again in December of
definitely not well dispersed in the
first place and you can see a constant a
constant dispersion during the
measurement so we start with a first run
in red and then it's the sample yeah
it's even finer to the blue curve that
gets finer to the green curve and so on
until one size so what you really can
observe here is that at this point we
had not a very dispersed simple and on
the analyzer I could continue this until
run ten I mean at some point probably it
will have reached its dispersion but
it's not recommended to measure that
resemble if you measure such a sample
there's only three runs you will have
three different results and you are not
sure if the vendor was really dispersed
yes no the other key element is the
technical periphery and the key element
in the technical periphery is
water supply water quality depends on
the mineral content of the water and the
presence of air bubbles in the water due
to the high delusion of minerals in the
water even very hard water hot water
will unlikely bias particulars results
however the background value detected
prior to measurements will likely
increase all the more important is the
effect of precipitated carbonates or
lime scale that will result in a higher
maintenance maintenance and cleaning
rate of the analyser and might
eventually be a source of contamination
in the measurement system from the worst
thing in terms of water quality our air
box
yeah brothers can occur in all sort of
laboratory water supply systems it could
be tap water could be distilled water
and as our brothers will be detected as
Pathak's
completely the gassed water supply and
measurement system is is indispensable
otherwise results will be biased by
ghost signals due to air bubbles and on
the next slide you see a set of
suggestions on optimized D gas set up to
provide air above the free water and the
system is equipped to run 24/7 and to
work with low maintenance so basically
the cold water from the tap goes into a
pyramid system and then we men pray for
the gasoline pumps water goes into the
into the Beckman to be used and there
are different solutions to this with
with water things but I think this
solution is a very convenient one and
there's a very low maintenance and I
think this is the most thing to consider
when you measure particle distributions
as air bubbles in the water will
definitely give you gold signals and
bias your results
and as if I come to the last chapter of
Metro the significance of the occurrence
of subpopulations within white particle
size distributions and I like to go back
to to this curve just again to show you
this last variability among different
and particular distributions of
different environments
and in the next few slides I want to
show you a study on a audience element
sequence in Southeast Kazakhstan that
highlights the significance of the
observed subpopulations and is exemplary
for results obtained from various sample
sets that we have measured in the last
year on the ls 13 320 so this sediment
sequence is located in central asia then
this is a region that is very famous for
its huge dust storms like these two
examples here this dust storm in
Uzbekistan in Tajikistan in November
2007 or the other ones that have storm
that occurred in the Taklamakan desert
in March 2009 and basically as a result
of this dust transport over long
timescales so I'm talking about several
thousand years or even there were 10,000
here if the deposition of Aeolian dust
that we call the ones it is deposited to
us and this is what you see here the
upper part of the Remi South color
sequence and from this other part which
is approximately 35 meters where I stand
we took samples in a two centimeter
resolution and the most outstanding
feature among the samples that of more
than 2,500 centers is a consistent
occurrence of two subpopulations within
the cell fraction so these these two
subpopulations here and these represent
too closely some peaks
in the particulars curve when one is a
approximately 20 micrometer and the
other one is approximately 45 micrometer
and those are separated by a very
noticeable gap and the variations of
these two subpopulations within the long
sediment sequence as we just saw here
before so these variations are not
random and they have reflect a signal
that clearly correlates with Astra
traffic stratigraphic position and the
paleoclimatic feature with in the
sedimentary sequence the causa 30 this
one here is pronounced within less
layers that indicate colder and more
dynamic deposition conditions why as a
finer peak here is strong and
stratigraphic layers that corresponds
with temperate climate conditions like
interest area and indexation complexes
and adjoining units and as this feature
is not only visible from this feature of
multimodal subpopulations not only
visible in this sequence so we can
really observe it all over the world and
all over the world in particular eyes
distribution curves that were measured
this higher resolution of instrument so
just this sample this figure here shows
you samples from Moss Iran from the
Mojave Desert and from the Tyrrhenian
Basin and Germany we all see this be
mole or if you are correct multi modal
particular distributions and to exclude
the possibility that sees subpopulations
could be a measurement artifact or may
be related to a mineral composition
service or something many colleagues
asked me in the beginning the scissors
may be related to the carbonate or mica
content of the sentiment we carried out
a set of test measurements to an
artificial produce silt in the
laboratory so we use the prom hat
finding machine to simulate glacier
grinding on pure quartz rock and
particulars analyzes of grinded product
show a clear boat be modal's the
distribution the similar sales modes as
we have it observed in natural sediment
so basically this is here one we thought
of cured quartz kleiner down business
from head machine and the rhythm the
distribution looks very similar to a
natural sediment here like this
less sample from Serbia in Europe in
addition it was found that amount of
induced grinding stress in terms of time
and rotational speed significantly
affects the appearance and accentuations
of these subpopulations so if you first
look on the left side here so we see one
run we the the center was crying that
for four hours with a rotational speed
of sixty rotations per minute and here
you see in other samples was the same
original material runtime four hours but
there's a rotational speed of only one
point two rotations per minute so you
can we see that not only time is an
important factor but although the amount
of physical stress and on the right side
is a nice experiment that was carried
out it was a disk mill dismissed if
mother had much higher physical stress
and the Pramod machine and we could see
that so these are basically always the
same type of original members who crying
it at five seconds ten seconds 20
seconds 30 seconds and it's very nicely
with opposite approximately at a
crowning time starting around 55 seconds
if a particular size distribution curve
produces a pronounced 20 gone these two
peaks in the cells that we have observed
before natural sediment and with the
slide I'm coming to the end of my
presentation and I hope that presented
case studies and the results
demonstrated that application and
interpretation of ticket size data that
take leverage from the high resolution
and application features of Beckman
Ellis 13-3 to 320 lasers I have the
potential to really provide a new
quality of data on particular dynamics
texture and physical properties in
Geoscience and source studies I'm really
convinced that it opens up new vistas
for enhance studies on particle size
dynamics in sedimentary environments
soil formation processes and timing
dynamics of landscape development and
this is last picture here taken in
Southeast Kazakhstan so you're basically
looking on the beautiful northern Tian
Shan Mountains I come to the end of my
presentation I thank you for your
attention and I will hand over this now
to Christine for questions and I'm happy
I'm looking forward to your questions
thank you very much and thank you dr.
master lei for that informative
presentation and yes it is time for QA
just want to remind everyone that if you
do have a question to ask dr. mesially
please do so now you just click on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen and click the send button we
will answer as many questions as we have
time for now let's get started
our first question is how do you
calculate the clay content using a laser
diffraction analyzer do you use the same
boundary to micrometers as in
sedimentation techniques mm-hmm yeah
thank you for this question let me just
jump to one one slide so yeah so
if you comment on this so the clay
fraction in sedimentation techniques is
usually defined as a 2 micrometer
boundary but I mean this is not a
boundary that is very strict and it also
means not that every every particle
below 2 micrometer is automatically a
clay particle or a clay mineral so there
are several cases where particles can be
smaller than 2 micrometer but are not
but it's not clays they are not clay
minerals so the boundary of 2 micrometer
was defined by sedimentation techniques
and for this they assumed that these
ladies very sled particles settle down
at a certain amount of time or at a
certain speed in laser diffraction
analysis this boundary is simply not the
same and there's a very useful study by
Kanade and Sundberg a-- from the 1990s
that showed that the boundary of 2
micrometer in sedimentation techniques
is related to a boundary of
approximately 5.5 micrometer in laser
diffraction analysis and this figure
here shows you that you this is not just
a just a theoretical assumption that you
can really see the sub population of of
clay in this slide here so basically
what you see here is this sub population
here and it has a very distinctive
boundary around 5.6 micrometer those is
something that relates nicely to the
study that was carried out by corner and
Thornburgh
so if people have concerns that laser
diffraction analysis might underestimate
[Music]
underestimates the clay cone and this
might be true as you if you said 2
micrometers as a boundary but if you use
5 point 6 micrometer I think you very
close to what you would measure the
sedimentation techniques but also keep
in mind that sedimentation techniques
have their disadvantage
in displaying the clay content and a
correct percentage
dr. Vasily how important do you consider
the detector resolution of the
instrument for Geoscience application I
think the the detector resolution really
really makes the difference so if we
just go a few slides back for example
one moment if we look on these samples
from from the soil profile in Germany I
think there's a lower resolution she
wouldn't be possible to see these
changes in the in the sense fraction and
I think this is really the key to obtain
real meaningful results and to get new
information so basically on this slide
here you see this vast variability among
the distribution because I search a
fusion course and you can also see that
there's several subpopulations and
there's a lower resolution of the
instrument you wouldn't be able to
discriminate between those
subpopulations but you can really use
those subpopulations as parameter for
your for your sedimentary record even if
it's climate studies or if you I'm going
to display some dynamics in a natural
system can laser diffraction
differentiate between smooth round
particles and jagged particles um I
wouldn't say so I wouldn't ever say no
and if you have don't have a if you
don't look the service optics on the
particles or let's say very simply
speaking if you take a microscope you
could from different rate between those
particles but the basic assumption first
it's a perfect ground particle but of
course it isn't I mean but also
sedimentation techniques assume that the
particle is
it's round but as we know Mika a
particle for example is definitely not
round so this is basically you have to
work with an approximation so you can't
differentiate with this technique of it
but and you have to keep in mind that
that there will be particles who are
perfectly round that would be particles
were platy
or particles that has long axis if there
are no more questions I would like to
once again thank dr. Bjorn Marshall a
for his presentation dr. mash lay do you
have any final comments for our audience
no I think you for your attention and
again I think Beckman Coulter and I
think lab foods for making this and that
semi not possible if you have any
questions please I would say contact
technical and they will put you in touch
with me and we can talk about some
things in more detail and also again I
would like to point towards our
application note that will be available
available this much and if you're
interested in this one please also
contact pregnant quilter and they let
you know how to get and how to access
this application note thank you very
much good bye and thank you again dr.
mesially i would also like to thank our
sponsor Beckman Coulter life sciences
for making today's educational webcast
possible this webinar has been approved
for continuing education credits again
please click the seee button at the
bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credit now
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through September
2nd 2017 you will receive an email from
lab roots letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now and we
thank you for joining us hope to see you
again soon goodbye